In central Missouri, about hundred miles from
St. Louis and right off of Route 66, sits
the small town of St. James.
Despite this town having only about four thousand
people, it is proudly the location for the
Tacony Corporation’s vacuum cleaner factory,
a giant facility that produces cleaners for
13 different lines and brands, including for
Maytag, Riccar, and Simplicity.
Sitting on the bottom level of this massive
factory is something even more unique, a museum
dedicated solely to vacuum cleaners.
Tom Gasko is the curator there and will delightfully
show off his massive collection of cleaners,
ranging from ones from the 1910s all the way
to a vacuum cleaner that joined George W.
Bush on Air Force One.
This fascinating museum takes visitors through
the rather unknown history of America’s
favorite cleaning machine.
Here, now, is that history – how the vacuum
cleaner came to be.
People have been cleaning the floors of their
domiciles for thousands of years.
Brooms, in their most rudimentary and handmade
form, were the common tool of choice for accomplishing
this.
However, it actually wasn’t until Levi Dickenson’s
1797 advancement of the broom that it began
to become mass produced.
The story goes that Levi’s wife complained
often about the brittleness and inefficiency
of her handmade broom.
So, Levi, being a farmer in Hadley, Massachusetts
and all, made a broom for her out of his toughest
grains, a variety of sorghum, a stalk of grain
used to feed livestock and used in the production
of alcohol.
In fact, sugar cane is a type of sorghum.
These stalks are tough, resilient, and quick
to dry – in other words, perfect for a broom.
Levi’s wife loved it and so did neighbors,
family, and friends.
He quickly grew more sorghum to keep up with
the broom demand.
By 1810, Levi Dickenson had also invented
a foot-treadle broom machine, which helped
mass produce brooms.
By the 1830s, broom factories popped up across
the northeast.
While a sorghum-made, mass-produced, reliable
broom was nice and all, it still wasn’t
particularly efficient.
It required a person to sweep for long hours
and use a lot of energy.
There had to be a better way to clean.
There was.
It was in 1860, with the United States not
so united and on the brink of a Civil War,
when a man in West Union, Iowa by the name
of Daniel Hess filed U.S. Patent 29,077 for
a type of device that would in the not to
distant future revolutionize the cleaning
industry.
In the patent, it is written,
The nature of my invention consist-s in drawing
fme dust and dirt through the machine by means
of a draft of air, and forcing the same into
water or its equivalent for the purpose of
destroying it substantially as will be hereinafter
specified.
This was the first known vacuum-cleaner.
Of course, he called it something different
– a “carpet sweeper” – and it had
pretty major issues.
Plus, there is no evidence he ever sold it,
much less created the thing described in his
patent.
Either way, Hess was proposing using a rotating
brush and a bellows mechanism designed to
shoot out a strong blast of air.
He also explains in the patent that “the
dust and fine dirt accompanies the air in
its passage to the bellows and from thence
down to the water chambers.”
In other words, he was saying the air would
be cleansed by water.
It is not clear either how Hess intended for
his machine to gain the power necessary to
do their work.
In 1869, Ives W. McGaffey of Chicago, Illinois
took this invention one step further.
In his patent (U.S. patent 91145), he sets
up his invention by saying,
The accumulation of dust and dirt/in dwelling-houses
is a source of great annoyance to all good
housekeepers, a large portion of the dust
being so light that the ordinary process of
sweeping sends it dying into the ain-so that
it is difficult to control or expel it from
the room.
He goes on to describe a similar machine to
Hess’s save for two important additions:
a hand-operated crank to produce power and
the machine standing upright, resembling modern
vacuum cleaners.
Hence, why many historians credit McGaffey
with the invention of the vacuum cleaner instead
of Hess.
Even with a crank, this was hard work.
As described by the book Vacuum Cleaner: A
History, “The faster operator turned the
crank, the faster the fan went, and, presumably,
the greater the suction.
It was with much work, but with little result,
but it seemed better than a carpet sweeper.”
McGaffey did try to sell his invention retail
for twenty five dollars ($425 today) and with
the name the “Whirlwind,” but found few
buyers.
For the next 29 years, the “carpet sweeper”
didn’t have any other significant (at least
recorded) innovations.
It wasn’t until 1898 when John S. Thurman
of St. Louis submitted a patent (U.S. patent
634042) for a gasoline-powered “pneumatic
carpet renovator,” that things started to
pick up again in the broom replacing world.
Thurman’s device “dislodged” dust by
blasting the carpet with compressed air, then
blew it into a receptacle.
There was no sucking involved, so it wasn’t
really a “vacuum” cleaner as we might
think of it.
His contraption was also not very portable,
but rather the size of the cabin of a horse-drawn
carriage.
So, Thurman offered door-to-door service in
the St. Louis area for four dollars a visit
(about $110 today).
He even took out an ad in the St. Louis Dispatch.
Thurman’s business was a moderate success,
though it wasn’t technically a vacuum cleaner
as we’d think of it, just a device that
did the same basic job.
It was in 1901 when Herbert Cecil Booth, an
English structural engineer, saw a demonstration
by an American inventor where, like Thurman’s
design, it blasted dust out and then blew
it away.
(Booth, in interviews, did not name the inventor.)
When Booth approached the gentlemen and asked
why it wasn’t designed to suck, he was yelled
at and told that no one and no machine had
been able to suck dust successfully.
Booth decided he was going to be the first.
He figured if he could just reverse Thurman’s
design, from blowing to sucking, it could
work.
Booth created “a massive gasoline-powered
and horse-drawn vacuum cleaner” and received
several patents for it throughout 1901.
He called his sucking machine a “Puffing
Billy.”
Booth also offered home service and it was
so popular that the British Navy called him
into service to clean London’s Crystal Palace
when a bunch of naval reservist came down
with “spotted fever.”
While Booth’s invention worked well, it
wasn’t compact nor meant for personal home-use.
But through the early 1900s, patents across
the world were submitted to try to capitalize
on this new innovation.
However, despite countless well educated engineers
and inventors trying their hand, it was actually
60 year old James Murray Spangler, a department
store janitor and hobbyist inventor in Canton,
Ohio, who invented the first compact, ready-for-home-use
vacuum cleaner.
Spangler suffered from asthma and his job
was to dust and sweep every corner of the
store.
Needless to say, he had constant asthma attacks
at work.
To solve this issue, Spangler made his own
vacuum cleaner from a tin soapbox, a sateen
pillowcase (as a dust collector), and a broom
handle.
Inside of the box, he had an electric motor
he pulled from a sewing machine which powered
a fan and a rotating brush.
The crudely-made machine collected dirt and
blew it out the back, where it was caught
by an attached dust bag (the pillowcase).
Unbelievably, the machine, dubbed the “suction
sweeper” worked well.
He was able to clean the whole building and
his asthma subsided.
He then set about perfecting his design as
well as patenting the machine.
After receiving his patent in 1908, he began
selling the machines, which were quite popular,
but Spangler didn’t have money to set up
a factory to mass produce them and initial
funds he received for such an endeavor dried
up quickly.
Luckily, one of his very satisfied customers
was his cousin, Susan Hoover.
Susan Hoover was also the wife of leather
goods manufacture William Hoover.
After seeing it demonstrated, William saw
the business potential for such a device and
had the funds to mass produce and market it.
He was also looking to diversify away from
the leather industry as the burgeoning automobile
industry was starting to cut into his bottom
line with fewer leather horse harnesses and
related gear needed.
So he bought the rights to the patent from
Spangler, formed a partnership with him, and
began mass producing his “suction sweeper.”
William Hoover was also a great marketer,
coming up with the idea of door to door salesmen
to demonstrate how the vacuum cleaner worked.
He also ran newspaper ads in the Saturday
Evening Post that promised customers ten days
of free use with the machine.
If they weren’t satisfied, they could return
the “vacuum cleaner” (named by Hoover)
free of charge.
By 1912, the Hoover vacuum cleaner had “sucked”
up the world and its dominance in the early
market resulted in many people calling the
vacuum cleaner a “hoover,” regardless
of brand, something that’s still true in
some regions today.